President Biden's non-stop appeasement
of Iran continues to be an embarrassment
for America the radical regime has been
firing off threat after threat to Israel
they might have orchestrated the Hamas
terror attack on Israel and iran-backed
Hezbollah says it's thousands of times
stronger than before and the Pentagon
says a US warship shot down three
missiles launched from Yemen which is
where Iran funds a proxy terror group
despite all of that Biden didn't mention
Iran during his address in Israel
Republican Senators say his weakness
needs to end now it is perplexing why
this Administration refuses to issue a
formal decision to freeze the six
billion Biden's Ransom payment made the
Iranians shows you where his true colors
are Joe Biden is the most pro-iranian
president we've ever had the great Satan
is not the United States or Israel it's
Iran I agree but going soft on Iran has
been part of the democratic Playbook
going back decades our very own Greg
Gutfeld laying out the
history the truth is the Middle East
always exposes the naive of past
democratic presidents back in 79
President Jimmy Carter took American
credibility into Bud Light territory
when Iran seized 52 American diplomats
it took over a year for America to
respond which we finally did by electing
Ronald Reagan Barack Obama was convinced
he could make a difference he thought
Iran could be brought around from a
fascist theocracy to a friendly Modern
Nation if we could just get that pesky
nuclear deal done Biden offers six
billion to Iran in exchange for American
hostages that hoses is more American
hostages right afterward like stairs
speed bumps and sandbags Biden never saw
it
coming Greg I know you're not into
partisan politics so let me put it to
you this way we're in an election season
do you think the Republican party or
Donald Trump or any of these guys has
made made the connection from Joe
Biden's policies to what we've seen
happen in Israel I'm sorry I I wasn't
listening I I'm sorry you know you're
lost in those blue eyes fixed right well
I mean we talk about the six billion but
that's nothing compared to the money
that Iran is making now under Joe's
watch that's the real gravy train he was
he's clearly they're clearly way better
off and far richer now with Joe compared
to Trump who tried to bleed him dry
which is the only language they
understand couple that with the fact
that we're committing energy suicide
here you know and we're now going to be
at the mercy of mulas and Mercedes when
it comes to Iran the letters us stands
for you suckers we think we can buy them
buy their friendship but they just take
the money it's just like BLM you know
they Swindle you and you get nothing for
it judge the president do you expect him
to mention Iran tonight or is he just
going to ignore it like he does the
Border I don't know what he's going to
do you know what I think he should do
but you know here's the thing Iran is at
War through proxies with Israel and with
the United States the Biden
Administration is funding the number one
sponsor of terrorism in the world it is
that simple all right and we keep
talking about the $6 billion dollar and
we ought to claw it back or I keep
talking about it anyway that's the least
of it they've made at least $50 billion
since Biden became president they're
selling their oil on the world market
and Biden says we're imposing sanctions
great Joe but you're not enforcing the
sanctions and the big news was they
identified 11 people that they wanted to
to to put some sanctions on and just
last month Biden and Yellen gave Iran
3.5 billion as part of an international
mon monetary fund that was last last
month so let's not kid each other this
is appeasement that has gotten us here
appeasements in 79 the bottom line is
Joe Biden is afraid of Iran he's so
afraid of them he's in a corner afraid
to even mention their name and if you
don't enforce sanctions they're
high-fiving each other saying you know
what
they're wusses out there that's what I
meant to
say Jessica what is the Biden policy on
Iran the Biden policy on Iran is first
that it would be better if we had the
Iran nuclear deal back in place which
all of our allies entirety of the West
is supportive of to make sure that we
could have the international Atomic done
well first of all that you would be very
H mad you're saying everybody wants it
Biden wants it the Europeans they have
to renegotiate the terms of it now
because we pulled out in 2018 that's
what Donald Trump did he said this isn't
getting us anywhere even though we were
able to actually go in and see what was
going on in the enrichment facilities
and he opted for sanctions instead um so
the Iranians don't want it you're saying
right that was the point that it's bad
for them so they wouldn't want it and
they agreed because there was relaxing
of other sanctions so it was a trade-off
for them that they thought was in their
best I think that's the way it went down
it it is the way what about forto what
about the fact that they wouldn't allow
us to even monitor what they were doing
they eight visits all right but Iran is
stronger than ever now Jessica they're
richer than ever they're stronger than
ever and they weren't like that under
Donald Trump that's a fact Donald Trump
of Hezbollah is very smart I liked how
you uh pushed on that this weekend
Shannon um
Donald Trump as solomani doesn't even
breathe anymore okay and uh BB let us
down was also one of his key quotes you
know he did Israel was never attacked
like this under Donald Trump I love this
stop pouring it back to tweets he said
it out of his mouth it was live um so I
thought that uh General Pat Ryan who is
the Pentagon spokesperson was really
good today I like
him all right end the show okay and he
said something that I thought was really
important especially for the media here
because they're coming at him saying
well I read this and I've seen this and
and he said don't conflate media reports
with the level of information that we
have and there's this assumption and I
get it that we're paid to do this right
we show up to work and we get the topics
that this is what we're going to talk
about and we have to prepare ourselves
but we will never know as much as the
IDF knows and we will never know as much
as the US intelligence agencies know and
he reiterated again that they are not in
a place to say that Iran was directly
behind this licit yes a huge problem yes
but not behind this and I think that
people need to start paying attention to
that instead of just you don't think
Iran was behind this I just I I think
they were certainly complicit I don't
think I don't think we can take anything
of what the intelligence Community says
at their word well I mean listen and
even if you don't want to to and there's
a reporting out there that they were
directly involved meetings in Beirut and
all kinds of things and planning this
but even if you don't want to buy that
you have to admit that streams of Aid
and other you know things have flowed
into Iran who gives $100 million a year
to you know we known terrorist groups
but you know one of the analyses about
this is talking about the fact that we
have lifted sanctions that the Biden
Administration has in exchange for the
promise that they're not going to enrich
weapons grade uranium and I don't know
most Americans are a little skeptical
about believing Iranians about that but
the tune of um they were capped at
775,000 barrels a day of Iranian oil
going to China it's now by some
estimates up to 2.2 million a day and
that equates to about $25 billion into
their cof so by one estimate this
Administration has done a lot to make
sure that they are financially more
stable yeah the Iranians in the cartels
those are the only two people thriving
under bomic Jessica hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else